응.
quantum circuit은 비즈니스의 가치 단위가 될 거야
qubit은 정보의 단위고
circuit은 연산의 단위야
그럼 quantum circuit이 뭔지 이해해 보자
그 구조를 살펴볼게
quantum circuit은 이렇게 생겼어
몇 가지 부분으로 나뉘는데 qubit은
이 수평선들로 표현돼 여기선 총
네 개의 qubit을 가진 circuit을 보여주고 있어
지금 보이지 그리고 gate는
qubit을 제어하는 방법이야
gate는 왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 읽어
단일 qubit gate는 단일
qubit gate이거나 다중 qubit gate야
거기서 controlled gate가 보이지
두 qubit 사이에 선이 있는 게 그거야
거기서 얽힘 연산이 일어나게 돼
그리고 마지막으로 측정과 고전적 출력이 있어
아주 중요한 게, circuit은 여러 번 실행해
shot이라는 개념으로 결과를 얻는 거야
shot 카운터는 결과를 얻기 위해
연산을 반복해야 하는 횟수야
그럼
어떻게 생겼냐고
2비트가 어떻게 생겼는지 보자
아까 그림에서 위상 변화를 소개했잖아
그 회전을 수행하는 연산을 아까 보여줬는데
그게 간섭 연산을 가능하게 해
그럼 고전 circuit과 비교해 보자
quantum circuit과 비교하면 고전 circuit에서는
파란 달 같은 건 볼 수 없잖아
회전이 없고 여기서는 다 분홍색이야
그리고 단일 상태들만 있어
이 gate들에서 창문 같은 게 보이던 것들
그런데 quantum circuit을 실제로
구현할 때 얼마나 대조적인지 봐봐
이게 우리 양자 컴퓨터에서 실제로 실행하는 circuit이야
너도 한번 해볼 수 있어
우리가 만들 circuit은
gate들을 조합해서
완전한 복소 진폭을
아까 보여준 그림처럼 생성해
왜 그게 중요하냐면
이제 qubit 간의 복잡한 관계를 위상 측면에서
생성할 수 있기 때문이야
그리고 얽힘을 통해 측정 행위를 하면
내부에서 일어나는 이 엄청난 양의
연산을 붕괴시켜서
중요한 답을 얻을 수 있어
그래서 결국 우리가
답에 도달하는 거야 나란히 놓고 시각적으로만 봐도
고전 circuit은 절대
방대한 연산 공간을 활용할 수 없다는 걸 알 수 있어
quantum circuit은 할 수 있는데
이게 이 큰 상태에 접근할 수 있는 풍부함에 대한 직관을 줘
우리가 이 큰 상태에 얼마나 풍부하게 접근할 수 있는지 말이야
그리고 아름다운 점은
다양한 종류의 circuit이 있어서
서로 다른 기능을 수행할 수 있다는 거야
예를 들어 이건 circuit인데
금융 리스크를 모델링하기 위해 설계된 거야
이건 circuit의 예인데
검색과 최적화 문제에 사용돼
그리고 이건 circuit의 예인데
분자를 시뮬레이션하는 데 사용돼 중요한
핵심은 다양한 circuit을 설계할 수 있다는 거야
용도에 따라 다르게
우리가 설계한 circuit은 그 다음
소프트웨어로 캡처되고 소프트웨어로 보관돼
우리의 경우엔 Qiskit에 보관해
Qiskit은 양자 컴퓨팅을 위한 오픈 소스 개발 키트야
이건 가장 널리 사용되는
양자 컴퓨팅 소프트웨어 프레임워크 중 하나야
그리고 circuit의 라이브러리를 구축하는 걸 상상할 수 있어
고전 프로그램에 내장되는 circuit 라이브러리를
고전 프로그래밍의 장점과
양자 컴퓨팅의 장점을 결합하는 거야